[Aplausos]
en este estado del sur de india el 30
por ciento de los 54 millones de
habitantes de la región trabajan en el
sector agrícola en los últimos 5 años
este territorio semi árido ha iniciado
su propia revolución y este hombre es
uno de sus arquitectos en la región
llueve muy poco por lo que en general
los agricultores solo pueden recoger una
cosecha del año
pero los agricultores que practican la
agricultura natural wow veía las
técnicas de cobertura del suelo pueden
cosechar durante todo el año y que kumar
aconseja al gobierno local que su región
sea la primera del país en dejar de
utilizar productos químicos en sus
cultivos un agricultor suele tardar
entre 3 y 5 años en hacer la transición
a técnicas 100% naturales hasta ahora
entre el 12 y el 14 por ciento de los
agricultores de la región han dado el
paso mi opinión estamos dando un giro
convencer a los agricultores indios de
que adopten métodos más naturales no es
una tarea fácil
formativo ya para ti es uno de los
conversos que ahora ayuda a fumar a
convencer a más campesinos de que
abandonen la agricultura convencional en
una de las sesiones de entrenamiento
verdad sí estuve allí es una pionera en
su pueblo y ahora hay 110 agricultores
de la zona de oro que le han seguido en
este proceso de carena manto por el
principio es sencillo pero el impacto es
enorme sólo con dejar de lado los
fertilizantes químicos y utilizar
métodos naturales
barbat y ha aumentado sus cosechas al
principio nos centramos en la
eliminación de los productos químicos
pero descubrimos mi caldo
cuando más desarrollábamos la
agricultura natural fenosa agua
necesitaban los individuos aunque no
llueva durante tres semanas y one the
first entre en los campos cultivados de
forma natural permanecen intactos
hace unos años la familia de barbate
estaba endeudada hasta el cuello como
muchos otros en la región pidió
préstamos y gasto las ganancias que
sacaba de sus cultivos en fertilizantes
y pesticidas al funcionar así gastamos
más de lo que ganábamos
así que no tuvimos más remedio que dejar
la agricultura durante 5 años
ahora párvatí y su marido dedican un día
a la semana para fabricar unos 100 kilos
de abono natural
mezclar 2 litros de zumo de hojas de
limbo estiércol y orina de vaca y un
poco de agua y dejarlo durante 24 horas
ese abono natural se fabrica
íntegramente con recursos que parbat y
ya tiene en sus campos
la mezcla debe ser bien agitada esta
altura también proporciona aparval y
ingreso adicional durante los últimos
seis meses ha estado vendiendo
fertilizantes a los otros una vez que la
preparación está lista sólo hay que
esparcir la por los campos y esperar a
que se produzca la magia con los
conocimientos básicos aprendidos párvatí
puede ahora dar ejemplo al resto de la
comunidad desde hace un año cultiva un
huerto con otros agricultores locales
para suministrar verduras a la escuela
del pueblo y a otros residentes gracias
a este pequeño jardín
hemos encontrado una nueva forma de
ahorrar dinero que no tenemos que
comprar las verduras destacar los
beneficios económicos de la agricultura
natural es la mejor manera de convencer
a los agricultores para que cambien su
modelo éste es un poderoso argumento que
vive kumar destaca durante las sesiones
de formación que organiza para las
mujeres agricultoras
pueden utilizar una parcela de su
terreno para un huerto y descubrir las
técnicas del programa gradualmente
esto le permitirá aumentar sus ingresos
y también
y apoyar económicamente a muchas otras
familias
[Música]
el programa de agricultura natural de
presupuesto cero ya ha mejorado los
recursos de muchos agricultores para
vivir kumar
las mujeres son un vector de transmisión
y de cambio que hay que favorecer
estas mujeres dirigen grupos locales de
autoayuda y son fundamentales para
convencer a sus comunidades de que
cambien sus hábitos aquí ya no se trata
de comprar toda una gama de productos y
llamar la agricultura se trata de
cultivar en armonía con la naturaleza
a pequeños pasos un agricultor tras otro
esta revolución está echando raíces en
andhra pradesh el estado del sur de
india espera que para 2024 6 millones de
agricultores cultiven 8 millones de
hectáreas de campos sin productos
químicos